wenn du wissen willst wie der Himmel
schmeckt dann macht dieses Steak Tacos
ah ja oh mein Gott wir arbeiten mit zwei
salsass wie man die beste Guacamole der
Welt macht habe ich euch letztens schon
gezeigt dazu gibt es noch eine süße
Salsa die auf Mango basiert los geht's
alles klein schneiden
jetzt gebe ich Tomate und Koriander dazu
und ordentlich Limette noch jetzt mit
Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken umrühren
was nicht fehlen darf ein bisschen Chili
die Salsa sind fertig kümmern wir uns
jetzt um Steak es gibt nur eine Art zu
würzen Knoblauchpulver Pfeffer und Salz
und wir legen unser Steak auf die Pfanne
schön Kontaktfläche schaffen unser Steak
ist fertig und jetzt können wir es ruhen
lassen jetzt gehe ich meinen Tortillas
auf die planschaft darauf etwas Käse
jetzt können wir auch das Steak
anschneiden gucken wir mal rein schön
zart und leicht rosa perfekt hier haben
uns mit Käse ordentlich Guacamole drauf
wunderschönes rosa Steak in Streifen um
drüber und dann finde ich mir das Ganze
mit unserer Mango sightse fertig sind
die traumhaften steakos bitte macht sie
nach